Ashley Judd opens up about alleged
sexual harassment by Harvey Weinstein I
thought no meant no the 49 year old was
one of the first actresses to publicly
accuse the movie mogul of harassment
it's been an absolutely tremendously
moving two and a half or three weeks now
she's revealing more about the day she
says she had to fend off his advances in
a hotel room fought with this volley of
nose which he ignored the Twin Peaks
star explains how she got herself out of
the alleged situation I just said when I
went on Oscar in one of your movies okay
and he was like yeah when you get
nominated I said no when I win an Oscar
and then I just fled judge says a few
years later Weinstein brought up the
hotel encounter to her and she put him
in his place he looked at me and he said
you know Ashley I know I'm not letting
you out of that little agreement we made
and I said you do that Harvey you do
that and he has spat my name at me ever
since
Weinstein spokesperson tells et quote
there were never any acts of retaliation
against any women for refusing his
advances his spokesperson also says
Weinstein plans to get treatment for the
next month for his issues and what I
would say to Harvey is I love you and I
understand that you are sick and
suffering and there is help for a guy
like you
and it's entirely up to you to get that
help